if you're tired of chafing from your
gross sweaty boxers listen up make the
switch to sheath let me see if I'm
wearing them right now yep look at that
sheath sheath underwear stops the
chafing and sweat with its incredible
design it comes with two pouches one for
your dick the other is for your
testicles these pouches keep things
separated so there's no more peeling
your penis off your thigh it's it's
great I wear them every day honestly
it's my favorite underwear L's favorite
underwear I get compliments like wow
that's good underwear my other
turns into swiss cheese not these that
rhyme look at that sheath was created by
US Army Sergeant Robert padon so you
know you're helping a vet here as a
solution for sweat and chafing in the
Iraqi desert so this underwear is
definitely going to hold up through your
trip to the local gym go to sheath
underwear. comom and use code drunk to
get 20% off your first order plus sheath
underwear's 100% money back guarantee
that's sheath underwear. comom promo
code drunk get sheath underwear support
the show support your balls
all right you know what's crazy about
Travis Scott he was banging Kylie Jenner
for a while and now is that the really
hot one or who's the really hot she's
like The Fake Plastic had the
billionaire one the youngest one which
one is kend 22 now Kendall's the hottest
I think yeah I she's thin and real
Kylie's the one that made the billion
dollars first the lip gloss or something
oh my God so it might be something else
I'm not sure but it was definitely yeah
something sex I think uh Blake Griffin
was there for a while oh I believe I
don't know shoes big shoes to fill but
my point is uh there was someone knocked
up a porn star in the net I think that
was also Blake
gri
twoce Bruce
Brown on the same team everyone thought
it was Blake Griffin it looks like Blake
Griffin's B I'm not saying it is but
have you Googled a picture of this kid
let's see okay Lana rh's kid oh she's
hard she uh he very much looks like
Blake Griffin I don't know I didn't know
she was I only know porn stars from like
2005 I still jack off to like the old
school ones yeah yeah I'm with you I
like them all okay now get put Blake
Griffin in the same thing this baby
looks oh
yeah let's do a little side by side here
it's uh it's some pretty St evidence you
guy oh and he's cool as okay Blake
Griffin Lana roads baby you got it no I
don't need to put a picture of Blake
Griffin no I meant ah okay I'm sorry I'm
on your staff for being no no
no this what he here for
youus on L roads baby baby there you go
by the way run by now now get that
picture in the second row look at
that the third row now first one the
Third first one in the third row first
one third there we go that one oh there
you go
wow okay maybe it's not his but but it
be it be a good episode of Mory for sure
a it would be the best not the father we
have Celebrity Jeopardy we should have
celebrity Mory that'd be awesome
oh yeah tell run by Jim what you ran by
us before I W Jim's take on this yeah so
I was telling them I think the
difference between men and women I
figured it out this weekend okay at L
someone
we've had so many people working on it
all these years and what about cats and
dogs so um my wife and I have a sick
friend in the hospital and we're going
to go visit her and she was like we
should bring flowers and I said well we
should just bring those that we have on
the table and she was like those are
from my mother's
funeral and I was like
and well that's what you reckon the
difference between men and women yeah
it's exactly what I said I like it I
think it's good it's not a bad was there
a card that said to the Dead person
there's no card okay so I'd have to see
the bunch of flowers cuz there are
definite funeral looking bunches and
gift darker you meant to go lighter for
the funeral it's like a white flower
event if I'm yeah lies and that
might be because of Princess Diana like
L but Google what flowers you it's
lighter color yeah that's that's that's
a funeral Bunch right there oh really
you're not meant to be like all drab
you're meant to that's secret admirer I
think that's what white is
no secret and isn't it isn't it Go white
means like friendship pink means love
and red means lust we used do a thing we
used do Valentine's day at school you do
this no no boy school so our yeah would
so at our school we did a thing where
for like a buck 50 you could write a
secret they would have banned this by
these days because it got too dodgy but
you could write a secret message to a
girl or guy or anyone you liked right
pay $150 and then one of the teachers
would come and deliver the flowers out
to the different kids and if you sent if
you sent white that was just to a m
yours if a couple girls would send each
other white so the you know the the more
offputting women didn't have no flowers
sure and uh and then the the pink would
be love and the red would mean lust or I
want to you it's code for I want to
you right and you'd see like some
of the more popular girls they'd be
walking out like with bunches like this
s all the fat chicks are just raw weight
yeah and you could write a little
message on there to your secret admir
you can they still let that happen now
yeah well we had the little chalky heart
that had a word on it remember it said
like uh your mind that must I I wonder
what was in those ingredients those were
disgusting foret about it you
never had those All American candies no
gooders I have a thing not Snickers
isn't bad but Snickers is better over
seas when it doesn't use American
chocolate American chocolate's really
bad stuff I'm playing and saying that
I'll be playing hery Pennsylvania on
Saturday I've been to the factory and it
it's l they don't go I'll go they don't
hide that it's like poison yeah they're
like oh it's all crap you watch them put
it together and they're like and you're
like that doesn't look like it should be
eaten by anyone but it's fun I did the
Lin uh tour in uh Switzerland like
couple of months ago I was out there
Touring that that'll kill you cuz it
starts off with there's just a waterfall
of chocolate sure and they give you a
spoon it's like a CH chocolate fact
they're Lake right you start eaten that
as you go along there Little Machines
you can put your hand on they'll shoot
out a button of chocolate into your hand
there and then at the end you go to the
ballroom and the ballroom is every lint
ball that's ever been produced and you
can take out as many as you can carry
everyone's filling up their t-shirts and
their pockets and with chocolate yeah
they just give it away oh wow you'll
die in the lint factory tour
you're going to lose a toe in there yeah
yeah jeez well that's fun but Hershey is
no joke that place is it's the whole
thing is built on chocolate yeah it's
just a town I did a real hell gig there
back in the day I remember staying the
hotel was like it looked like we're
uh what's his name from no
country of old
men yeah with an air gun remember that
movie I've never seen that movie I know
it's one of those movies that when you
say you haven't seen it people get
really disappointed it's just a good one
yeah it's good it's great I only
saw uh casso the first time for the
other day that's fun jeez you're a movie
guy aren't you I like movies you I like
movies but but you know there's just
ones that pass you by and then you feel
like ah looks like it's going to be a
hard watch Like No Country for all men
I'm like that'll be a hard watch and
everyone else is already seen it who am
I going to talk to about it yeah you
know the wire is like that you seen the
wire like I don't know I don't have 30
hours afan used to have that bit I want
to talk about heat now oh yeah right
that's great you guys seen heat yeah oh
heat was one that I just saw but I just
saw Casino Casino sort of is one of
those ones that after the film you
Google the real people yes and that
looks nothing like the Nero oh dude he
like in the movie like Theo like got the
tie and all type of stuff Sharon Stone
was his like hustling sort of hooker
type of chick was looked like Sharon
Stone and the real two of them looked
like uh car park fu yeah there we go car
park the only one that got her right was
Monster she actually looked pretty
similar to that I mean she'll never be
as ugly hours in a that's that's the
that's called Brave when when when an
actress does that they we're allowed to
play outside our race right you're not
allowed to play outside your race why
are you allowed to play outside your
looks ah I get it that's ugly
face those jobs should have gone to the
ugly people right Jo Joel Edon is it
what's his name Taran Taran Ed Taran
ederon Edon Edon or whatever he played
Elton John and Eddie The
Eagle right he's one of he's one of the
best looking guys guy what a hunk yeah
he's and he's he's meant to be Eddie the
eagle or Elton John like they have to
ugly that guy up all of a sudden you're
right if you have to be trans to be a
trans actor you got to be ugly to be
ugly and ago should play Elton John
Eddie the eagle got an inspirational
movie about him just because he was ugly
yeah they went can you believe that an
ugly man can do ski jump any of the
eagle was not mentally challenged in any
way there was he had no physical problem
wrong with him right but they went this
is inspirational an ugly person
achieving and and he came last
we love he was missing an arm you got a
movie right just thick glasses yes well
anytime an ugly person does Susan Bole
we're like holy she's a talent but
it's just cuz she's hideous yeah but
she's really a great singer she's better
than Taylor Swift I used to do a joke
years ago what was it about like look
about like yeah that's anything oh I
should bring this joke back I never
record this joke but it was basically it
was like if you want to win an Oscar you
what you do is you act go disabled right
your Forest dumped it up or you're my
left footed or something like that but
it's I've in the few acting jobs I've
had whenever you've got something like
the character's got a limp that makes
your job a lot easier it's when you're
playing like a normal person if you
think the person has a twitch or they've
got something they do with their hand or
they smoke or something you've got
something to do all the time it's right
disability is the easiest of all the
acting oh yeah right it really is the
easiest you just you get into it and off
you go yeah right but I I want an Oscar
for a disabled play player normal
like someone with now that's acting
someone like severe cereal por yes right
and then you're watching like how they
made the movie and he's like when we
made the film and you're like oh he
was so good the acceptance spe like
that's it you got it yeah wow na
it yeah yeah I should bring that bit
back that was all right that's a great
bit it's true you want oh we were
talking about legit before you got here
cuz that's like that was a great show oh
yeah I thank you I was very proud of
legit but it was one of these things
that that everyone who watched it
enjoyed it and no one watched
it but it it uh it was no I was very
proud of that it was um it was it was
how I met Brad Pit it was one of his
favorite sitcoms so you got that first
joke in there that big story about the
brothel the brothel brothel bits in
there the whole thing uh well that was
true a friend of mine with muscular
distopy we took him out to a brothel we
actually did it in Melbourne but you you
you have to fudge things so we made it
into Vegas stuff and I remember watching
the first episode uh we I wrote the
script and it was like we go out to
Vegas we'll go to the brothel we'll do
this we'll do that and then um we filmed
it in Portland so the drive from LA to
Vegas is very leafy it looks like a Bob
Ross
painting as we're driving through a
little hooker over here and then there
was happy
mistakes that's all we have and uh
uh and so the the girl and you you met
Kate when I as soon as I met Kate right
so I met you like I want to say 12 years
ago or something or maybe more well no
it has to be uh 11 years 12 Years cuz my
son's about to turn 11 and I got her
pregnant about a week after we met
because we were still drinking yeah
right so so yeah I got that was a really
fun weekend I got her pregnant like two
months after meeting her yeah and uh
yeah so my son just about to turn so
over yeah about 12 years wow um but uh
uh yeah so she played the prostitute in
legit oh so I like first actress I
worked with are knocked up like I
really up I really I really set a good
PR it probably stopped me from getting
in more trouble you
know well good thing you never work with
Kathy
beats so there she is there's Kate so
Kate Kate Kate so I always get to say
that to my to my son I always get to go
when I met you I employed you when I Met
Your Mother I employed her to work as a
prostitute well you were paying her Anu
fuor so no that was it I just not like
sure sure yeah it's not like that wasn't
for the acting
right you had to learn the role you know
you had to resarch this is your first
acting rle and you knocked up a I did Co
yeah I didn't take long yeah it was me
first acting job it's I always go on
about how easy acting is and I think we
can say it cuz we're on strike but
acting is I'm not the best actor in the
world but if you watch that I do a
possible job yeah you know what I mean
like acting your bits so you on stage
you do like but it's like never really
had a lesson no no it's sort of an easy
it's plan house it's make believe and
there's a m like Daniel de Lewis Marl
Street this next level but anybody can
do the middle ground yeah yeah that's
the whole thing the elites there's
people who do another step above where
you're like ah they really good
exactly they're really good it's the
same with comedy right there's people
who could kill in Ohio and they
stinks but they're passing they're get
it's a passable job but this is this is
like the 80% of any great sitcom is
casting like like at the end of friends
you could have got had chimps writing
those scripts
sure those six would have delivered it
perfectly they just would have same with
Seinfeld they knew all their beats and
how to do it and they just the casting
it all comes down to Casting that's the
weird thing about Hollywood it's like
it's like uh you'll develop a project
for years and you'll go written this
script and then they'll give you notes
and they'll hand it back and then then
some executive will get fired and
they'll get moved to another Network and
then and then eventually you'll get
right up to now we're going to make it
it has to be cast in one day ah you're
like that's the most important bit I
know did you did you cast uh the rest of
the people on I can't I I well that's
the weird thing you feel you never feel
like more of a a fraud then when you
you're you've never acted and you're
judging people's
acting you've got a script and you're
like are you're going to be reading with
me I I'll be playing the part of Jim and
then I'm reading like an ape right
right and these people are putting on
great shows and they leave and then you
like you comment oh that person wasn't
very good or that person was good you
think Jes who am I to talk am I I
had another sitcom that never saw the
light of that was 6 days out from being
filmed Med um and I was going to do a
multicam for NBC and we were we were
this close and then Co happened ah damn
then we got put in but like they had the
whole sets built at Universe Anthony
leaga who you might
know yeah he was playing me dad nice
yeah yeah we decided to bond for a bit
like we just uh we were like he was like
if I have to play your dad he goes we
should uh I should your
mom he go he goes we should should drink
or we should so we used to get high
about once a week together to try to get
a rapport one that father son high
rapports this is the part of acting no
one tells you about that's his lovely
wife so so yes we can all say that
Anthony's doing just fine good for leega
yeah yeah she's very nice girl as well
she's she's a Melbourne girl hell yeah
but that's Australians for us crushing
I'm going I'm going there for the first
time next week wait wait wait before me
Melbourne Sydney uh Adelaide Brisbane
where are you performing in Sydney I
don't know yeah I never know either you
just go the theater they're going to
drive me to and the thing I'll have a
look at you have a look at this great
crowds you're going to have a blast oh
you're going to love it and they know
American Comedy where is it at Brisbane
at the oh the enmore I did that one the
enmore the enmore is my favorite alltime
theater in the whole W killer okay so so
I go over there and do like like I can
do like a big room where I do a whole
multiple n Wars you know what I mean cuz
I love love that room so it's a
beautiful theater beautiful and and it's
in a it's in a real sort of hip part of
town so it's sort of like if you ever
been to London it's like the cam and
place going you best Thai food on Earth
they reckon all around there really yeah
best Thai food on well it's all the same
Thai recipes but they reckon there's
better produce in Australia or something
there's some argument that new town
where that theater is is the best Tha
food in the world is's an argument that
makes sense here first that's look I
don't always agree this is I'm just
telling you what these people people say
but yeah you'll have a great time man
the pet theater that's the nice that's
next to a fun park on a pier at
the Melbourne is like 3,000 you're going
to love it that's a beauty you you're
from Australia but you started in
England right or did you move there
quickly I did I did four months in
Australia or five months in austral I
was always going to England no matter
what you know the comedy scene still
seems small there I was jumping around
to Bar shows and it felt like okay so
you got to think like when I like 20 six
years ago or something when I did my
first open mic or
whatever the comedy industr so
I I only saw Comics perform for five
minutes and on our version of a Tonight
Show every two weeks they'd have a comic
and then there was another TV show
called The Big Gig where there would be
like 10 comics doing five minutes every
Saturday it would be local P people but
if I saw an international act they'd be
on this Tonight Show and and we didn't
have HBO so we didn't have any standup
specials to watch I never saw anyone do
the more than five until Delirious came
out right and then that was a cinematic
release so you could get that at the
video store oh yeah you must like your
mind when saw George Carlin to me was
Rufus from Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventure and Richard Pryor was the guy
out of the toy and all crazy we didn't I
never saw him like like you know my
parents didn't buy the vinyl or anything
like that so where was I going to get it
I had no friends who were interested in
standup comedy it wasn't culturally as
much a thing wow so so I just sort of I
got into it just through local blocks in
Australia and what you know I think part
of it as well is there's nothing will
convince you to do standup more than
really bad stand-ups being around you
I'm not saying I'm not saying they're
all bad but I don't know if I would have
had the guts to start it in LA or New
York if I showed up to the seller and
just like I want to give this a go I'd
watch onean and be like I can't do
that that's too good but in Australia
you could go I think I could do that
booster for sure the levels the levels
help cuz you go to an open mic and
you're like I'm better than that guy
exact just need that ref I think it
would be very easy to start n over my
night you'd be like ah you could
take over that town in 3 weeks
it's like being an eight in Cleveland
you know you're like hey I made it you
move to New York you're like oh I'm a
so true but if you didn't see Carl
or anything were you going on up and
like oh man there's so many premises out
there that no one's tackled yet you're
doing Seven Dirty Work One S started to
get into it then I discovered it but in
my teen years oh wow I didn't really
know that much about you know going but
then moved to London and did that
circuit for 10 years and then came here
and but I really I still very much um I
I would say comedy wise I I I identify
as British if that Mak yeah yeah if that
that was the TV and stuff we watched is
right you know we watched that like in
Australia we had like a lot of like
money pyth andu like that on the TV all
the time lot of British sitcoms not much
American stuff interesting cuz now it
feels super American everything's super
American yeah and now they get they get
Netflix and they seeing all the specials
and now I feel like the comedy style
over there's much more leans to the
American Comedy style now that's why we
can tour over there I mean that's that's
a thing like 20 years ago they we're not
doing that yeah I got off the plane like
you know Bobby Lee my C I love they're
obsessed with podcast and all that
what's Rogan like how tall is he you
know but the crowds are great that and
more you're going to love it you so you
went from England to LA right uh I went
from yeah England straight to LA but I I
sort of did LA back and forth for a
couple years living in both like it
wasn't just like a hour moving right and
it was it was uh it wasn't like a plan
to move to to America I was just in my
20s was like wherever the world
takes me man did Montreal then got an
agent oh there you go you know what I
mean and then you go all right I'll come
down and things were happening for me in
the UK and I remember thinking ah I'm
starting to do theaters there I should
probably just stick that out something
but then I think I broke up with a
girlfriend and then I was like it
that's when all best things happen right
when you've got no one who loves you
when you when you have no one who loves
you and you're living by yourself you go
I might take a risk right it's when
you're strapped down with these things
that adore you where that's where your
life never progresses yeah Rock Bottom
is all way up you know yeah I can't
leave this person it loves me I can't
leave this person I have to feed it yeah
and you got a you had a viral video
early with the punch I was just going to
go there the punch well that was it yeah
I just I remember cuz that was about
2006 and then I just booked my first uh
theater to and these were like 400
seeders or whatever three like but I was
out of the comedy clubs right yeah and
and the ticket sales were going okay but
then they went straight through the
because this was before everybody had
camera phones exactly so before everyone
had camera phones there was only one bit
of footage of this happening in front of
400 people was the surveillance cameras
which was the the the tape that you
asked for after your set to see how your
set went me wow that's real the CCTV
footage yeah that's the only footage so
it's a great it's a straight on angle
and uh you can see all the people I
don't need to watch it I've watched it
many many times I the only footage the
only viral clips of Comedy back then
were you getting punched in Michael
Richards that was
it well you I also edit the bit out
where I started
saying that's when you can control the
narrative yeah that was CRA and then you
come back out you Riff on it and it's
like yeah I I it was I remember I
remember okay so Michael McIntyre who's
probably umug the one the biggest or the
second biggest uh uh Mickey Flanigan's
right up there as well in Britain these
are the arena selling Comics right and
Michael McIntyre was on before me and
Michael's very funny he's like a British
sort of Seinfeld type actor um but he's
a smug basted Michael and me and Michael
had a mutual respect for each other but
uh we like stirring each other up you
know yeah so I get punched in the face
he's watching the footage on a on a
screen he sees it happen and I get punch
in the face and then I I I go through
the backstage door and there's a little
tunnel to walk through till you get to
the actual Green Room he hears me coming
and he quickly changes the channel and
he turns it over to just like snooker or
something you know in Britain they're
just like watching darts and and he's
just like seeing like and I've got like
a black eye and he and he doesn't even
turn around the face me he goes how did
you
go and I go no not good Michael they
they just they just punched me in the
face and he went like this no one can
follow
me that's killer wow yeah you had a lady
get a heart attack or
something yeah everyone's had something
like you know EMTs I've had a edur
festival so that's just me doing my own
show in a little room in case people
haven't been to the edim festival it's
so maybe I was in a 200 seeder or
something like that so it's very obvious
and the show is just an hour and it has
to be an hour sometimes with these
Edinburgh shows people like PowerPoint
and screens behind actually that was the
year I had a screen of the punch and I
had like I had one of those pens to be
like a football referee and I could show
you where the different people
came yeah um it's so funny cuz that's
usually such like an all comic move but
you're literally breaking down yourself
getting punched in the face which would
never happen those rooms were like the
safe rooms you know literally getting
attacked and like was like a bar type
environment or no were the people jumped
on stage to defend me and then since
then it's Manchester so there was four I
think four blos came up and started
beating up the you know I didn't have
security like Chappelle right here's
here's a weird one okay I'll tell this
bit first anyway um uh so but now in
Manchester when I go
back every bar I go into it I meet one
guy who jumped on stage to help me oh
classic cuz I've had to buy beers for
about 300 people right right who claim
to be the bloke who protected me
I can't one of them has to be telling
the truth so I bought if you ask
me I'd buy a drink thank you for that
you've just opened a bad door for
yourself they already know words words
gotten out I think there some people on
their second go around yeah right you're
going to meet someone with a New York
accent you're like I don't think you
were there OAS is going to come up to
you
hey what was I saying before that I oh
Chappelle I say Chappelle I never met
Chappelle and then uh La Comedy Festival
happens he's playing the Hollywood Bowl
and I'm at a party and I get the the
I've never met Chapel but I was hanging
with my friend Jimmy car there I think
Jimmy was actually opening for him at
the bow right so I was meant to be there
I didn't I was allowed to be there and
uh and he waves me over I I get told
that Chapelle waves me over and he was
very nice it was a pleasure to meet you
can't believe we haven't met before I've
watched your stuff I said well thank you
Dave I've obviously watched your stuff
he goes he goes yesterday Bill Burr was
showing me a video of you getting
punched in the head oh and he goes and
this is the first time I met you he goes
that was some crazy I
talked and I sort of had the little
conversation we've just had now and all
that told the joke about the people in
the bar and all all this stu stuff
and the next night Dave
Chappelle gets hit on stage at the
Hollywood Bowl wow that's crazy and I'm
sitting at home like wow it's like the
Domino
holy he go I can't believe someone
let that happen where was the
security and then Michael McIntyre was
going how'd it
go like Jimmy K was say how did it go
he's on next week yeah Jimmy car oh he's
on what here yeah yeah oh me and Jimmy
have been mates for years he's uh he's
one of the nicest men in comedy he said
he didn't know you ah it doesn't matter
it doesn't he doesn't have to remember
me to be nice he's I'm an a memorable C
man but at least Chappelle had a
mob up there you know he said John
Stewart was like stomping the guy oh
this is the whole thing he had he had
blanks that beat him up so bad I had to
have audience participation I didn't
have that's even better though I feel
like sta would give him more of an ass
kicking especially especially what he
had which was guilty stuff right right
like bodyguards who were there too late
right oh they're going to break an extra
limb oh yeah oh yeah they're going to go
hard did the guy have a weapon on him
too he had a knife he had a had a gun
that had a jack knife that came out of
it so a replica looking gun with a knife
that came out of it I hope that I'm not
the dumbest spreading a rumor
I'm doing Chinese Whispers or something
like see I I got to okay the way okay
you guys call the game telephone yeah in
the rest of the world calls it Chinese
Whispers And I don't know if I'm being
racist when I say it a you're feels like
it might be a racist thing to say but we
call it Chinese Whispers that's funny
that's cuter I don't I don't know I
don't know where it comes from it's not
like they whisper more than most or do
they well they are very quiet people I
feel the Japanese whisper more than the
Chinese yeah especially when they're in
the
bush buy that made a terrible hor
Chappelle said uh that it was a gun that
identified as a knife which I thought
was pretty quick that was a gun that
identif he did that's hilarious so he
got a Zinger out of it damn what but
that's like a dangerous weapon to have
you're going to get you see a gun
they're going to shoot
okay so that's the photo of the guy
there he's all beaten up he looks like
his arm's broken yeah yeah he he doesn't
look in good shape but you know did you
hear what happened afterwards mm so so
nothing happens to him no charges no
nothing I think there was a little oh I
did hear maybe because he got the
beaten out of him so bad he could have
counter sued or something like you know
what I mean like it was I I don't know
I'm just speculating that right but then
like a month later people look at the
photo and it's like hey that
murdered someone right run yeah he's
like man if you're a murderer he's
gotten away with it stay on the download
lay low a little was he offended by a
bit you run on stage and hit me but
don't hit Dave Chelle you know right you
know yeah go hit Ian bag or something
what are you doing don't do the
Hollywood Bowl get someone at coconuts
in in in in Toledo right right the
biggest room in La what was the motive
for that he was like a non-binary or
something so he was mad about the trans
jokes wow yeah so
were upset
yeah there you go perfect that's where
we're at we we've offended
murderers yeah all right we'll cut all
this out cut cut all this while you're
cutting this what would you rather have
you rather have like uh are we really
cutting this yeah we cut good man I
don't want to get involved you out
of your mind don't dodging that
I think there's a Keo Reeves
quote that's like I'm at the age but I
don't want to get involved in
discussions right if you say 1 + 1 equal
5 you're right it's a to yeah just agree
agree agree move it along there's too
many c yeah we were at a game
yesterday and they just took me like
they I'm playing the MSG theater on
Saturday so they were you know they giv
me a nice treatment at the game and they
were uh they took me to some I I knew
they were supposed to take me to another
room but they're like you're here and I
was like okay oh my brother was like are
we lost I'm like just they'll settle it
out I don't want to I'm not going to I'm
not going to be the dude who's like
actually I'm like no just I'll chill
here got a problem
I'm not saying back to the
show yeah yeah cut all that good though
if you want to bring up me uh you know I
me nephew died just try to spit
that try to work try to just work it
into the podcast coming in with some
real zingers over
[Laughter]
there I remember when we first met you
were I forget which hour was it was I
think it was after
alcoholocaust yeah alcoholocaust was me
best work that was well that was the
brothel bit that was the brothel bit
yeah that was the best and it was only
called aloh Holocaust after the fact
because I was I was so drunk when I made
it that I was like uh really yeah I
better name this something to act like
it was meant to be oh that's
funny did you black out during that
special I I I don't remember making it
no and I didn't remember making it the
next morning completely didn't know I I
what yeah I were you Terri that you like
I just did an hour of I don't know how
long it took you to write I've had that
with women yeah and I yeah and people
spent money
andwork was it that's hilarious at that
stage that was for showtime and Showtime
just did a small recording of it but
actually cuz I had the HBO one and then
I couldn't really get another special
for a bit and then I got and this wasn't
like I would have self-funded one but
that this wasn't in the era of
self-funding specials and just releasing
online yourself and getting the money
doing and then I got
uh I recorded that one myself I think I
put my own money out for that or
somebody put money out for that one to
show on British TV and it was sold to
Showtime so it aired like four times and
then it's gone and then I did one on
epics and that and then epex did that
end up on Netflix afterwards no that
one's if you want to see that one
there's loads of copies of that in me
garage you can see that was one was
called fully functional that was not a
bad I think online seen that though no
oh it's around I think it was on Netflix
I think you can buy it on app Apple or
you know I mean I don't think it's I
don't think it's hard to get to and then
and then I did started doing just the
five specials on Netflix and that's been
the easiest bit is without having to
sell to different you know she used to
be they just a Netflix is the
best thing that ever happened to Comedy
best best thing that ever happened to
stand up comedy because you I go
to Asia now I can sell little theaters
out to people who have Netflix
yes exactly and it's on all the time
competition is good though I mean I
think it's if Amazon can like get it up
or
don't get me wrong it I'm just
saying Netflix cuz they really started
doing it because now if you get a
Showtime special it's streamed as well
all of them are I don't know if
it's easy to watch Showtime though like
you need app or something it's fine you
just watch watch show to on the
Paramount app oh there you go who has
Paramount though me man I love
Telly no one loves TV more than
me you know what if I I'll tell you pet
ha of me K who don't have TVs oh that's
weird oh Fu now it's not as much a brag
cuz you'll have a computer or an iPad or
something it's not as much of bag but
about 20 years ago when you met a
who was just like I have a mate who's
always always like yeah I don't watch TV
don't watch TV you no that's
weird don't you don't need that in your
house it rots your brain what type of
yeah had the call him
about 9/11 didn't
I he was he was the last to find
out cuz he he never left his house he
was always practicing drums and stuff
you know what I mean like that's the
happiest man of all time thinks they
never attack he always thought he go I
said what what do you do I read books
you're getting old
information you're not getting any new
info that's true you got to wait for the
paper that's it yeah the paper the news
man but people do that now with social
media I'm not on social media I'm like
well how do you talk to people or get
around or I don't have an iPhone like
how do you use GPS or email there are
people you see people I could go off I
could go off large because we're on
large social media where we have people
we don't know following us right that's
where the problem is I could be in the
social media with the people I actually
know like those 40 people you know what
I mean that be ni that's what social
media is to most do yeah the average the
average civilian social media looks like
a lot of fun I just comment on Jenny's
holiday and I really like Jenn yes
exactly brilliant she had a
pretentious quote I can Zing her and
then I'm out yeah and then I can say I I
can actually compliment someone's kids
without looking weird because I've met
the kid you know what I mean but now
social media we have we have to
congratulate people we know for getting
movies a yeah you got to do the fake hey
good job congrats chariss
Daren I've never met I was talking about
other comedian oh okay okay I don't know
Char used to run oh I'll give you your
number no one's commenting like my
brother has Instagram and it's like not
a lot of follow it's just normal the
comments are just normal that's what
it's for no one's no one's calling him
Michael Phelps with Down Syndrome yeah
you know what I mean sorry about that I
put up on my social media uh when's this
coming out so it doesn't feel next week
oh okay okay so so just after Halloween
I put up on my social media a picture of
me and the wife with the baby Halloween
blocked out the baby's face cuz I don't
like to show me children and I very I
very rarely put my personal life up on
my social media I just put work stuff
chat to some people in the inbox but
very there there they all that's great
so what's the the comment section
the comment section is just people
on me about how pretty my wife
is and how old I look right all right
you could have done worse like reg yeah
exactly like here's me bitching I'm
complaining about how pretty my wife is
right but it's like you don't get that
just on the little regular yeah the
person with 30 friends like there's
people literally writing that liting on
that on there she's in it for the
money exactly like is there anything
more insulting to how ugly you might be
what do you mean she's in it for
the money my my I've been paid
throughout my life literally for my
personality you think I have no good
redeeming qualities I know right
it's it's too much my wife's always like
how come you don't post about me more
I'm like cuz I don't want people calling
you a yeah that's all they'll do
oh my God I get comments sometimes like
you have a speech disorder and I'm like
well I make a living as a public speaker
so my jokes must be pretty good
yeah I'm not offended by that I enjoy
on my speech I don't know yeah
someone Zing one day they'll make a
movie like like the King speech where
they go through your speech disorder
until you're eventually ready to go on
stage ah we'll get that Taran egod into
to
plug going be he's going to take his
shirt off like oh look at look at Sam's
ass sweet he's in some show he's
in some show Blackbird on Apple have you
seen that dude he is shredded really
yeah he shreded he shredded he keeps
shaving and looking more effeminate in
prison I know not a great plan hey hey
hey Teran stop looking
when you go you're about 5'
five don't go into prison looking
yeah right try to make yourself
as unfuckable yeah just like stop waxing
your chest that's your first thing your
first thing you've gone to to prison
stop waxing your chest yeah Let It Go
who are you doing that for he kind of
there's you're sort of asking for it at
that pull up a picture of his face he
kind of looks like hot French Stewart oh
okay do you see it a
little like a French Stewart was like a
really hot dude I could see it yeah he's
going to play Matt R in the movie
although I guess Matt could play himself
he's hot enough
yeah what a
hunk those lips I haven't I haven't met
Matt or if I have met Matt sorry Matt I
don't remember he's a really nice guy
he's a really nice guy a lot of people
want to on anyone having success
that's what we were talking about when
you blow up overnight people are going
to be furious but yeah he's been doing
it for a while he he's been cutting his
teeth doing it found the Tik Tok thing I
don't do the Tik Tok so I can't
be envious it's not like I gave the Tik
Tock a go when I put all the same I put
all the same Tick Tock effort in he did
no could you imagine if when tick came
Tik Tok came out I was the guy who
always did that popped up and sort of
did something for 10 seconds hell
no you don't want that he's bringing a
hot girls into comedy great great bring
the hot audience we haven't had anyone
since Dan Cook bring us hotties over
exactly we've been starving over here
all the comics like Louis CK never
brought in the hot girls for us no no
John
Panet it is funny when you do a show
like I I did a come on Gaff lift your
waight you're not bringing the H right
during Co I did a split headline show
with Jared freed and uh his whole
audience is hot chick he true so it's
literally like we just see my audience
and my dude it's just my audience just
dude skinny dudes with one eyebrow with
a drinking problem and he's got hello to
Liam
Gallagher you're buddies with him right
no i' I've met no once I never i' I've
met well I've met Liam but I haven't met
Liam I which one's the hotthead one was
like a Liam's the Liam's the Young one
who was a bit mentally uh just you know
not going well but now he's bigger than
his brother and his brother was his
brother the one who wrote all the songs
oh okay and so one had the Charisma and
one had all the talent and sort of with
together they couldn't you know it just
shows that we like hot people yeah cuz
he won in the end yeah yeah the other
he's the good-looking one both won yeah
sure sure great documentary by the way
about 50 exactly yeah it looks
great yeah yeah yeah that's what that's
what that's what 30 cigarettes a day
will do for your kids in a drinking
problem keeps you looking all good keeps
your hair in your head do you still
smoke no I don't I don't smoke I don't
drink I get high there you go I'm a
little high right now what was the last
St for
drinking I had so many last
draws I like I had like they go what's
your rock bottom and you I got like 10
Rock BS like they were all like sort of
equally you were you were so
funny drunk though you were dude I
remember being out with you and you were
never not you would like land perfect
insults on people while slurring it was
it was very impr my best special I was
blind drunk yeah when I when I had I
still the the funniest I've ever been is
drunk the funniest and also so the best
shows I ever had I was blind drunk the
worst shows I ever had I was blind drunk
there could also be a crying moment yeah
right I could I could turn to crying I
never really turn to Agro really I never
really an angry drunk but I I would turn
to
oh you I can tell the audience tell
the off that's a weird closer yeah
yeah then you leave you know I had a
couple of those but I had some great
drunk gigs where crowd surfed
out of the room and everyone was
like this guys a maniac wow and so
Ralphie May tried the same thing that's
how we lost
him but now I have good shows and I
don't have the really low shows or
anything like that what were we talking
about cuz I was drunk something cuz I
was the last oh the last straw the last
straw
ah there was it was sort of during Co
and I hadn't gone out to drink and uh
for a while and so I went into the
comedy club and I was like I'm out
and about I haven't been out of the
house forever and look there's people
walking around and I've got a mask on
but I'm vaccinated and all this type of
stuff I'm going to have a drink and then
I blacked out I did two shows and I woke
up asleep in someone's house that I
didn't know I didn't shag anyone or
anything like that like I woke up like
in a dodgy environment yeah the only guy
who wakes up like Oh i' shot bear or
Freedom about that and I I I I you know
I'm a dad and I I've done that several
times in my life but I was just like
this man and then I took up weed
and I really enjoyed it I took to it
because I never did it for years and I
was always a Coke and alcohol guy you
know so what really happened for me was
I gave up the cocaine and and then when
I go out the cocaine I couldn't control
the drinking because I became a sloppy
drunk and as soon as I became a sloppy
cocaine used to straight me out it was
the one thing keeping me
sober right great and then I stupidly
gave up that yeah right and then I gave
up the drinking and it was all right cuz
I stayed High and the drinking was very
hard to give up but I went to I went to
a few um AA meetings and it wasn't
really for me I don't like sh I don't
mind going to therapy and talking
one-on-one with people but I don't like
sharing a lot you know I feel like I do
that so much on these things and so much
on stage on I don't want to do it weekly
and tell you how my week's been I don't
want to really live just how I feel
about therapy now I I do so many
podcasts that I show up to a therapist
I'm like oh I got to talk to you too
now yeah and it's not monetized what the
hell you're in there stamps.com and I
was I was going to AA in Co on these
zooms and I was doing it with a lot of
of comedians they were all really nice
and they were really supportive and they
were really sweet but me if
comedians don't like to share right and
it felt like there was a few open
markers in the
AA they were using their alcoholism to
make connections oh I'm sure that happen
networking yeah so so uh clue too man we
should write
together so it's like the shares
were meant to be like I thought about
drinking but I didn't drink and I got
close and it was the you know
anniversary of my brother's death or
something like that and made me think
about drinking but I didn't drink and
I'm real proud of myself that's what
they meant to be but this was like Yeah
Tuesday reminds me of a Tuesday back in
1984 and there was some people there's
some people in like there's some people
that like got AA and they're like so and
then they relapse and they so and they
relapse and you sort of look at I'm like
oh you're not trying come on you're
never allowed to say that you got to go
ah we support you you like that cun's
relapsing tomorrow yeah you can feel he
knows he's going to do it just wants to
feel good Monday to Wednesday relapse
Thursday to Sunday and then oh relapsing
is part of the Cure so you watch that
like real and then you got other CS in
there where you're like it's been 42
years since my last drink and you're
like then don't do this come on
you're fine right go away yeah you're
good you're taking up my time now that's
true years cut off I want to hear the
people who are going through divorces of
lost jobs give me some good stuff yes
Rock and so in the end I gave that up
and then when I gave that up I went all
right and I was getting high not not too
much but a little bit you and then I
thought I'll give up the smoke and I
Vaped for a bit and I I gave up the
smoking and when I gave up the smoking
I'd never been more proud of myself for
doing anything ever I never felt better
about myself because that the other ones
were easy because it was stupid like oh
why would I take cocaine you
idiot you're someone's dad you're all
you know and then it's like why would
you bloody drink and look like a
buffoon in front of people and then when
he got smoking it was such an addictive
chemical that was in me to actually beat
that was felt like a real achievement
and then when you tell people about
giving up drugs they applaud you give up
alcohol say that you're or so but you'll
get a parade you say it on stage
you say you say hey I don't drink
anymore people start cheering and
your fans were cheer I thought they give
you some of them do but like and
people come out congratulations
congratulations congratulations but you
give up smoking which is the hardest one
and you get all you get
nothing people are actually mean to you
they go why did it take you so long it
was a disgusting habit say like you
might already have cancer you may have
done it too late and you're just like a
what I doing that yeah be nicer to
smokers who are given up it's really
hard did you read the book how'd you do
it cuz everyone says it's the hardest
thing ever I just one day I just went
this and just stopped stop hacking
away at your ball hair with a razor that
isn't fit for the job manscaped has
everything you need to clean things up
down there they've launched the fifth
generation performance package featuring
the allnew lawnmower 5.0 Ultra to get
you in tiptop shape when you're going in
for a close shave below the balls below
the belt sorry when you're going in for
a close shave below the belt you want
the best of the best right you don't
want just any blade near your nut sack
it could slice it up and leave leakage
or blood or whatever probably didn't
need to go into that kind of detail you
get the point the new trimmer features
two interchangeable blade heads one is
for taking a little off the top the
other is a new foil blade for smooth
close shave with three length settings
and uh waterproofing you can get any
look anywhere I use it all the time you
know I got a little jeo surrounding my
ball sack I want to make sure it's trim
as always manscape skin safe technology
helps prevent Nicks snags and tugs so
you'll always look and feel your best
get 20% off your free shipping with the
code drunk at manscape.com that's 20%
off with free shipping with the code
drunk at manscape.com your balls have
been through enough it's time to go
Ultra with manscaped cuz I tried
hypnotism and I tried going to these
special gurus I tried ringing the Allen
car and work a little bit but I was
always doing and if you think about a
cigarette you do this and if you think
about that you do this and then you do
this thing and then you distract
yourself and all these little tips they
give you they give you they give you and
all that was making me think of smoking
and also I was like the guy relapses
drinking all the time I was like I'll
just have one cigarette cuz I get
stressed or whatever like that whatever
and in the end I just went don't don't
do it anymore ever again this is dumb
whoever does this as a idiot
damn you should only be breathing
oxygen into your l you shouldn't
put anything else Vape or nothing you
should never put anything in your
lungs you'd have to be a
to put something in your lungs
wow just like told your that and
I'm never smoking again wow damn and I
don't even want one you know when I see
people smoking I pity them whoa
I actually pity him I just go look at
that poor bastard he's
trapped or if it's a she I go oh she's
up for very
R very rare of me to smoke her these
days I just have one she might be a fat
girl that was part of the thing with
smoking wasn't it my she making a bad
decision I smoke very very little and
very little and then I ramped it up when
they banned smoking in England because
that was in my early 20s that was the
way to meet girls because they stopped
us smoking inside and because it's a
rainy Place they' always have a little
tiny awning at the front of the
nightclub or the bar so you'd all have
to be tucked into this little area and
then the girls who smoked as I said they
were always a bit more fun yes you know
they're up for you know they're a bit
more fun we have an expression here ha
if she smokes she pokes yeah oh really
yeah and then also I don't I wasn't
saying that I mean like you can have a
laugh with them and have a few I wasn't
saying I was going to them right
away but I was just going to say they're
not uptight but you went straight to
poking that's what I that's what I meant
I went they're not you know they're
going to party they're F they're smok if
you smoke cigarettes you're a dirty
that's what say put that on the
box heyy my mom
smoked anyway did your mom really did
she did but she gave up by the time I
was born there you go um but uh but
anyway so what was I talking about so
you get get out of the and also you have
you got a light you got a cigarette
girls would walk up to you especially
because girls they don't pay for things
like cigarettes or cocaine or anything
like that just find someone to give it
to them they go I have that thing and if
they're attractive you go you can just
have that for free hot girl privilege
that's yeah that's that's it that's
that's a currency there you go have so
that would be the best way to meet girls
but I I I look at like smoking on stage
like that as a premise if you go like
the London Comedy Store it's like a 450
seat Club where all the seats are in
theater mode right down from the top of
the roof to the bottom so the roof is
only about 9 ft high right and
down to the stage one way in one
way out and we would smoke in front of a
curtain oh yeah front just a in a
basement right in that tiny stage in a
tiny stage yeah we used to finish the
show there used to be a comedian who
finished the show called Chris Lyman and
his closing act was putting a Roman
Candle up his ass and lighting the
firework in the room in the basement
there next to the curtain bigger
influence on steo yeah but oh man have
you seen steo special year no is it it
is a multimedia why I know he gave me a
special link it doesn't come out yet but
he does a stunt it's like he
talks he does some stunts on his new
comedy special which are the ones that
were too risky for Jackass whoa right
that's fun one of the best his bucket
list of stunts right yeah one of them he
gets someone in with a legal like cuz
you you can't medically get this this
this medicine had to be stolen they
steal epidural medicine that you give to
pregnant women right as they give birth
this is a big needle that goes into your
spine and uh it makes you paralyzed from
the waist down right pretty that women
can give birth another great way to meet
women yeah so so make you paralyze from
the waist down right so he has that
there's no man should really get this we
don't give birth so he gets this
injected into his spine and then he sees
how long he can run for oh that's great
you already know it's great that's great
and he doesn't and he also does doesn't
do it in like a he's got this blood
coming out of his back he doesn't do it
in this like and he has to get some
shady doctor it's like illegal to do
this like the the doctor's hands shaking
and then he doesn't do it in like a
sterile like like in a sterile room he
does it in like a dirt track
where Bulls would have cows would have
been and stuff wow what a gag
so how does it look is he just like yeah
he runs runs until his legs just stop
moving and then he just dumps and then
he's just try to drag so and his legs
are bear trying to drag himself along
with his arms it's he said he was
getting breast implants for his next he
he wants to get he wants to get breast
implants he reckons he can get them for
about two months the doctors say any
longer than that the skin will stretch
too long and it won't look good well it
sounds like he's really using quality
time of doctors productively so yeah
well Healthcare is tough to get he is uh
the the the the special starts with him
on his roof we give to much away no no
no no I'm I'm plugging it he came on my
podcast to plug it so he's been on here
we love Ste I I love St great guy I want
to I want to plug it for him he starts
the podcast with Bill Burr picking him
up in a helicopter with a ladder
dangling off it right they really did
this as the opening as the opening Bill
bur flies a military sized H it's really
is Bill Burr right with a ladder
dangling picks up steo what right flies
him along with steo dangling off the
ladder they they did this then Ste he
hovers over a moving tour bus oh my God
and steo jumps off then swings in the
door from the top hugs his girlfriend
goes this is my special dude you know
whatever he says you know the steo voice
Jesus this is so much better than my bit
about cereal a hell man it's
like wow how you going and it's like
it's like now I'm make a Netflix special
and they're like this you don't need
backdrops backdrops aren't
in right and like d an intro straight
into the jokes I'm like st's on
a helicopter man I can't believe he did
the first bit in a Kobe jersey that was
where I drew the
line but wow and then he has to follow
that with a full hour that's insane I
I'm pumped I mean I don't I don't think
he went straight to the gig I reckon
they filmed him on separate days to be
honest with me that's I will go a limb I
think there's a bit of you know there's
some trickery going on there yeah he
swings into the theater yeah because
when he lands on the tour bus and he
gets in it's still daylight and I had to
assume the show is at night right it's
in London good it sets a lot earlier
there yeah I don't reg he went straight
to the show that's true also the bus
doesn't even look like it's driving
through England so this it looks like
the bus looks like it's out like those
Flats where they do the land speed
records where you're allowed to do
stunts right like Nevada or something
yeah some in Nevada yeah they weren't
even driving in England so yeah I think
it's all a shame ah what a hack
don't watch it don't watch it I've I've
changed me mind on it and I think Bob
newart did that you a while back
so wow good for steo now that brings up
the question Brian Cranson did a movie
where he's in a wheelchair he should
have to get the epidural just to keep it
real well yeah I reckon oh that's the
thing I'm Legit so DJ quals plays the
guy with muscular distrophy thing for a
while and we didn't know this so this is
11 years ago he was getting CU now we
had all the other actors were disabled
actors except for the one actor which
which DJ was cuz also who wants to work
a person with muscular distrophy for 12h
hour days you know what I mean tough
like who wants to say that like
no another hour we got to get the shot
like off I'm not doing that that's
true right but he he got accused of
face they called it is short for
there we go isn't that offensive and
also yeah I'm like the you something you
can't can't say face yeah
exactly that's too close to spaz face
you know what I mean like you don't all
the r word I isn't it isn't it baling me
I'm like I can say spaz and then I go
the r word hey got to draw the line
somewhere no not like okay Bloods
and Crips no who was the other guy in
the show I me who is the your
best friend on the show the bald guy Dan
badal he's great yeah D backo
man he's in everything he's in like vep
and uh oh yeah uh one time I had an
audition for a movie and uh if I'm
talking too much and
you I had I this audition for a movie
The Heat right and in the heat there's a
character that was an albino cop right
and I got real far in the auditions
where where I was like I'm going to I'm
going to get this part right I'm
GNA I think I've broken inside oh no
it's still there um I I go I'm going to
I'm going to get this part I'm going to
get this I've had call backs they
started checking me how I look in and
out albino wig with blue contacts like
it was that level of like I was getting
and so I got I got a phone call from my
agents and they were like it's between
you and another guy this big movie
Sandra bulock and you know
McCarthy I'm like all right between me
and another guy and then I sh up to work
and he's like this hey I go how you
doing he goes I'm doing great I just got
this part in the movie as an albino cop
and I was like there can't be two
films
so there there he is it's the albino cop
holy wow look at that yeah they
made the right choice he is a funny
looking fell yeah and he's whiter than
you I think already yeah I'm pretty pale
fell but uh but yeah Dan uh yeah Dan's
very funny man we we uh he he lives just
up the road for me I got up to his house
about once every two weeks and played
pinball with him hell yeah and I buy a
pinball machine he buys a pinball
machine and then we're border the
machines we swap them with
there you go so you always have a new
pinball machine hey that's great do that
with wives That's next we have there's
wife we've done
that have you have you been close to any
other movies that would be funny if that
albino part went I I had one I had when
I first moved out here I got an audition
for a movie called uh extract an extract
had it was a Jason baitman film with
milakunis
directed by Mike Judge gee what a and I
was I I had audition after audition for
this film I don't know this one and uh
and then they go to me they go it's
between you and another guy once again
between you go we'll hear something
today right all right waiting and
waiting I'm waiting they went with the
other guy and I went all right who's the
other guy and they went Ben
Affleck that's you I me what what are
you talking about Ben Affleck yeah what
do you mean what the are you
talking about Ben how was I competing
with Ben Affleck and they went you
weren't competing as such they were just
doing the mathematical equation can the
guy we get for 10 grand give us the same
box office as the guy we get for 4
million it wasn't a big part yeah they
were like what is the best yeah best
deal yeah or they were waiting for Ben
Affleck to go no yes and then they'll go
we'll just give it to this guy who gives
a it's a small part no one cares
but they're literally calling you the
poor man B AFF ah no no the the the poor
cheap mans just the horrid mans the plan
no one cares
mans right ack damn well if it helps I
never heard of this yeah no one ever saw
the film that's the only other time that
there was like a big movie where I was
like I I tell you what I did I had an
audition for Obi-Wan Kenobi recently are
you kidding me and what's his
name I always want to hear OB say
k m um what's his name aiz anari Nani
yeah that's I'm about to say the other
one my wife's Indian by the way I should
mention that at this stage I should
mention my wife is Indian I'm allowed to
say the other one the other
one that's uh as soon as I said it I
knew my wife won't be listening she
doesn't even know about the smoking
so kumel uh is Obi-Wan or he's he plays
his like con man uh in obiwan Kenobi
like other Jedi who meets who the guy
who's the guy who plays obiwan Kenobi
you know the BL you and McGregor you and
McGregor right and there's this scene
right and he's meant to if you've
watched aan K there's meant to be this
scene where the guys like uh he like um
you he's doing a bit of Jedi stuff mind
reading stuff for this bloke and then
he's helping families pass through this
passage way and he's taking some money
go you can not know who I am and he's
dressed up as a Jedi and he's acting all
Jedi
and uh so I did that bit all in an
English accent and went you cannot know
what's going to happen there might be
people watching me as we speak we should
be careful like this right I'm doing all
this stuff right and then he gets caught
by Obi-Wan Kenobi and then I thought
what I'll do is I'll because he's a con
man I'll switch to back to an Australian
accent right and I was like oh no I
don't know what's going on oh I'm really
sorry um like that I thought this was a
real funny choice right
right anyway my agents and the people
who are casting it did not get this
choice and they just thought I forgot
the accent
after and they were like that was the
worst audition seen they go it started
off really good and we were really into
it and then you can you not do that
accent the whole time and I'm like what
they go they go there's no one with an
Australian accent in space is what they
told me and then I yeah but Boba
fits from New Zealand
bro fet Mari fell and all of a sudden we
can't have just sort of like a slack
Jord country Australian voice you know
we're taking a few leap of faith we got
t St Wars yeah exactly but you can't
have Leah die and go or Leia and go
no no no this this accent definitely
limits Parts you can play right so
British people can do romantic comedies
Australians can still somewhat do a
romantic not as good as a British like
like like a Hallmark romantic guy can be
British yeah love actually yeah like
like some woman who meets a British guy
oh I'm awfully sorry o oh did you forget
this thing they can do all that
yeah B and and but Australians it turns
out now we can do action because you got
like that Hemsworth right okay
well you had Mel Gibson by the way Mel
Gibson
yeah he didn't always do this Russell
Crow Crow does the accent right he's
actually from new but his accent more a
strin you know I mean but uh we can't do
villains you can't have there's never
been a BN villain who's just being like
well he
[Laughter]
can't he's just like he's just like
patting a dog yeah what what's
your name K right right it doesn't sound
smart James you m you you
think you can come in here
I've got I've got a laser
pointed at the moon and I'm going to
blow that up
so a cat a
kangaroo v a koala yeah but hey I'm
Southern same you can't have a
smart guy with like how y'all doing you
know you know the unless it's like a
bait and switch you know true yeah
that's you don't have a Southern accent
at all no no I got rid of it but now we
can do we can do the action because of
as you said we got Mel Gibson we got
have Russell cow but like if you watch
that extract with uh Chris hamsworth so
we watched this it came out I believe
Mother's Day and on Mother's Day we all
sat down me and my sons and my wife and
one of my wife's friends and we watched
extract and Chris Hemsworth comes on the
screen and he's doing that Australian
voice that's really deep down there like
okay what's the mission and what do we
have to do yeah there's a certain bloke
from Australia who speaks like this he's
like tough but he also sounds a little
bit caring right that type of voice
right and so I go up to the bathroom and
as I come down I hear my wife talking to
her friend and she goes the Australian
accents my wife's British she goes the
Australian accent's never done it for me
before she goes she goes but on him like
that right like yeah not like she she
really meant it right I'm like
hell and I came in I said seriously you
want me to speak like this all the time
de you and my wife jokingly goes yeah
like that right cut to later on that
night where in bed me and the wife are
about to and my wife asked me to do
the Hemsworth oh jeez she goes she goes
just do that voice I'm like you
serious and she and I go really you
really want me to speak like this and
she was like getting off right
so I my wife as Chris Hemsworth oh
my God but you can't do that to her you
like come again yeah exactly and then
afterwards my wife says to me and she
meant it she goes if you can sound like
that why wouldn't you just sound like
that all the time not my
voice wow it's like it's like okay and I
think this uh comic's really funny but
uh Melissa via seor yeah yeah she's
great she can do like any voice she can
do like that Marilyn Monroe really hot
voice but her own speaking voice is it's
kind of goofy yeah it's kind of goofy
why wouldn't you choose the all right so
now you're siding with the wave here huh
now you're siding with the wave I well
maybe I should walk around no but I'm
just saying I'm that's what yeah why
don't I try to sound like a hot
Australian all the time like I always
thought growing up like SNL people could
be freaky in the sack cuz you could just
do any voice I never thought about that
really that's what you think
freaky you you think the best in
the world's Jeff
Dunham I wanted to get rail By Dana
Carvey think must be
freaky well you just have access to any
type of
character I did not Sam
real well yeah never thought about that
though you got something there well I
mean you just said it with Melissa like
she can do any voice well I always took
guys so Eric Banner right yes you know
he was a stand-up comedian I did not
know that so this is a thing that
Americans don't know that Eric Banner
was a very popular standup comedian in
Australia to the extent where Eric
Banner had his own TV show called The
Eric Banner show damn what where he did
sketches and stuff like that there he is
playing one of his characters Peter
um but
he yeah this is his sketch show but he
also did stand up he was an impersonator
he also and then he started
impersonating people one of which
impersonations was
Chopper but this is why this guy cuz he
was an impersonator was such a banging
actor he could impersonate
anyone so he just could become he could
do any accent he could do anything
because he was a coin like put in Eric
Banner swartzenegger
Jamie Fox right he could just do any
impression he could do any impression
and when you can do any if you can do
Impressions you can do acting right it's
a good point you're doing characters
yeah what's his face so here is Robin
Williams yeah Australia also great
great to be here all right so so how
does it feel to be the star of a of a
Batman and Robin
film well it's funny you know when
you're little little boy you know it's
not great but you know what I'm saying
like that's what he used to do on
Australian TV and then he never did
comedy again right of course as soon as
he got so his first movie was like
Chopper and then his next movie was the
Hulk and then his next movie was
Troy Jesus chist and he like Brad Pit
this guy and he was a standup comic like
six months earlier I had no idea it's
weird it makes me respect him less I
don't know I'm a standup and I'm like he
it's de I want a
loser well that's what they do they've
tricked us into thinking that we do is
no I this is it actors are
acting's it's 10 three
times a 10-year-old is one an Oscar oh
great point you can never have O'Neal
was good though yeah but you you
never have a 10-year-old great standup
comedian you can never have it D pull up
some of those Clips they're so
bad it's great they have uh yeah pull up
there there's a whole Instagram page and
then read the comments it's the
greatest thing you've ever seen
10-year-old just yeah like little
there's no award for comedy performance
There's No Award for best comedy but who
has to host the Oscars boom us cuz they
need the show to be entertaining yes and
they're if they're so
talented entertain that crowd of people
for three hours without us here
here so true and then and then we'll you
know then the SL and there's no
Comedy Award you mean you can't throw us
a the way the way they looked at
that man after he slapped slapped him
and went and comforted the man who
abused the comedian who didn't do
anything wrong was outrageous
agre the whole acting Community every
single one of those actors who
stood up for that man when he won the
award should be ashamed of themselves I
agree not violent you got to help each
other bam we're not going to do a thing
yeah well hashtag all day the more we
learn about Will and Jada the more
insane they see like she should not be
doing a book tour they haven't been
together for six years but they still
living together right no no they live
they she just said they've been
separated for 6 years I thought they
were still in the no they live in
separate houses the the same
street basically me and my ex live that
way you want the kids to be able to walk
between the houses and all type of stuff
you that's the ideal situation but if
you're sleeping in a separate bed in a
separate house you're not together yeah
and it's like when do you like what
would have be done for her while he were
still together gone up and stabbed the
like you know what I mean that's
doing for someone you're broken up with
for 6 years you're slapping someone get
the out of here I tell you that
never would have happened if Will Smith
was Bal if Will Smith was bald
cuz balding people losing their
hair right I have no
sympathy for her losing her hair
no one has any sympathy for men losing
their hair no one no one lets us wear
wigs it is harder to be a bald woman
than a BAL she can wear a wig she had to
wear a wig we wear wigs where
losers if we get if we get hair and we
scoop it over like this we're a
loser if you got thin hair you're
allowed fake ponytails and you're
allowed extensions in your head get the
out of here walking around with all
your hair then one of them one
of them goes Bal and you're all
outraged if you he I'm with
you yeah I I have I have zero
sympathy for a woman going bald over I
have as much sympathy for a woman going
bald as I do for man going Bol much
equal amount of sympathy which is a lot
yeah no one's helping Jeff Ross no yeah
he looks like hell the weird about you
made a bold joke about Jeff Ross he's
I don't know if he's maybe his
wife's a girl he's we looking to slap
someone that's true that's a good point
yeah the 22-year-old he dating is just
going to see another man right exactly
yeah and it's weird cuz if you have a
com over you're either a joke or the
president you know like Trump's got
up okay so Trump doesn't have a
comb over I know what Trump has right
please okay this is I'm the only okay
I've had a hair transplant now when you
get a hair transplant you take the hair
from back here and you put it up there
like Jenga right everyone knows that
these days right they pluck the hairs
out they put them up the top now when
they do that um these hairs back here
never grow back right I've I've had one
and my hair back here is a lot thinner
than it was before you can you can take
all the hairs out there and just
scar tissue he's had about six or seven
hair transplants over the years and they
keep on removing hair back here and they
put it up here so he does have hair
shitty hair up here right that whisps
around now what he has is so this
there's a rectangle at the back which is
just Freddy Krueger like scar tissue
area yeah right so you ever notied on
the side he has that hair that whips
over his ears yes pull it up okay that
stuff there there grows down past his
nipples like like he's like acidic jewy
type of it's way down there so he gets
that and he whips it behind his head to
cover up the square at the back of his
head which is all scar tissue and
he's the only man on Earth to have a
comb behind ah over and that's why the
back of his head looks like a duck's ass
there it is yeah look you can see in the
wind yeah it's blowing over to the front
yeah so that's why he grows out those
side wings wow you wonder why he has the
wings what's the point of the Wings cuz
you meant to keep the sign short to make
that top look fuller yeah he has the
wings wow this is a big breakthrough
this is huge look I've tried to tell
people no one listen to this is huge
news look look look I will say right now
to Donald Trump I'll give half a million
dollars of me own money to any charity
of your choosing if you will show us
current footage of you getting out of a
swimming
pool being fully submerged and I don't
want to be political on this I didn't
come here I didn't come here to this
about hair yeah this is just about hair
and I hey and and my respect for the man
a good com over deserves as a
Bolding man I got to give it to Donald
Trump he has for everyone says
he looks like he's a man in his 70s
and he's trying to look his best the
fake turning
he's doing the comb over in the
head I tell you what you can't say you
can't say the hasn't put effort in
well unless unless you're talking about
his diet I mean he's not he has a
terrible looking body yeah yeah he only
weighs about 190b or something 215 he's
63 yeah that was the I I interviewed
Sean Spicer on TV show he was all right
he was a nice enough BL you know what
Sean Spicer was Shan Spicer was a bloke
who who got a really big job and he
couldn't believe it either yeah yeah
it's like cuz no one wanted to work for
Trump and he's just like a guy was like
I was just like working in the mail room
or something I don't you know he had
that feeling to him yeah they bumped me
up yeah and I I said I said do you
really believe that the president's
25 and he's like he's like well if
that's what the doctor said I said well
I'm 250 and I'm I'm I'm 4 Ines shorter
than him right so I just are we sure
yeah that's the only numbers he has in
he goes what does it matter to you I go
cuz if you can lie about this he can lie
about anything but I mean I'm 200 and
I'm 6'3 he's not he's not he 6'4 or
something he's taller than you oh wow
he's taller than you and how how and
you're 200 200 yeah and he says he's 25
get the he's like he's like he's
250 he's 250 if he is a day maybe more
you know what I mean if he is a day map
look up a kid doing standup comedy Legos
oh yeah yeah 10-year-old's doing comedy
I'm sorry I wouldn't sh I could think of
the right one but this should be on
Instagram and it's worth it just for the
comments all right is it I don't know
pull it up this is Kevin spacy's
Favorite yes here we go how cute is this
kid but I'm the best Lego
builder
ever if you don't believe me I even have
a room dedicated to
Legos I build Star Wars Millennium
Falcon Harry Potter chess set
and a trick out
Bugatti and when my parents aren looking
I sprinkle the smallest Legos on the
floor and wait for them to step on them
it makes me
giggle I love it ah it wasn't as bad as
you think you've never been a parent and
stepped on a bit of Lego that's like
this is this is like when this is like
when George started getting into B yeah
he's pretty good he's got some stuff I
fing I'm with you mate I've stepped on
Lego my my dad my dad used D saying
about Lego was the only good thing about
Lego is the sound it makes going up the
vacuum that's not bad yeah well George
is lying I like stuff you don't have to
think about too much it's great line
yeah the the jar is round the mug is
round no round team I I sprinkle the
Lego on the ground so me parents will
step on it good good ending the bad kid
if you ask me yeah well how's the
comments I'm I'm scared to see is it
just Jared F liking it you might have to
go to Instagram now let's not get into
cut cut St bad instincts I don't want to
read people on a child like
what is that wrong with you people you
we were just earlier on we don't have
kids we no we were earlier on saying
people were calling you down syndrome
Michael Phelps and it was
terrible well he's putting himself out
there as well this is the these
comments stuff like that and then a
10-year-old has it going you go
let's look at the little C's comment
I know but he's like playing in the
NFL he's going to get hurt he's too
young it's going to help him develop
he's he's going to be 14 he's going to
be like so some guy told me I looked
and that's his new his new
chunk all right let's cut all this he's
probably right well we praised him too
may maybe he's got the goods he might be
18 if he's 18 or something now coming
away there you go you know what you're
right he's of age cuz now he should be
look back on that with shame yeah you go
we all make Ser if he can look back on
it with shame but if he was just cut
that cut that part a little kid he's
going to be huge too he looks like a
Lego now I I I I I'm sure your fan base
is going to call me soft for sticky no
we should cut we should cut it no this
is good stuff you're defending the kid
you're making a good point yeah I'm a
monster oh you're fine no you're not
you're down syndrome
Michael he swims at a pool
we don't want to be drown you know I did
used to date a girl who dated Michael I
remember yeah yeah used to be one of me
bits I dated a girl who dated and she
was a nice girl if you're listening
hello um I got nothing against that uh
very nice lady um never met Michael
Phelps but I always remember having sex
with her thinking to myself I can't be
putting as much effort in as Michael
Phelps No way there's no way that I'm
and this was him at the Olympics getting
six gold medals right oh my God he's
probably her with them on just
clanging yeah yeah yeah like like and I
was smoking and doing cocaine sweating a
lot in those days sweating a lot there's
no way I was giving her as good a
performance like hold his breath for
like four minutes literally this was his
whole job this was a man who could eat
whatever he want cuz he was burning
20,000 calories every day so he just had
to keep eating cuz there was too many
calories being burn off if I eat like,
1500 calories I'm going to be fat yeah
he I haven't moved he's eating that ass
I a woman I date a woman who had
sex with Liam niss once what and I tried
to I tried to do I tried to do a bit
about it but it would work special
skills exactly I I do a bit about like I
don't know if you ever watched
Schindler's List and gotten even sadder
oh that's funny never hit never once H
good did you run a train all right we're
back oh
my oh my this is a bad sign when like
you guys are I can't say that Joe cuz as
Australians we can't be villains you
[Laughter]
see never going to okay there could be
some historical movies with the
aboriginals I'm sure we could
look as long as it was in Australia the
movie was Australia Crocodile Dundee had
a few this episode's going to be like a
minute and 45 seconds
long I have asked Paul Hogan to be my
father
about three times wow every every time I
do a sitcom where I had my dad involved
or a develop like I had that one where I
say Anthony the Pug and then and uh
what's his name played um my sitcom in
legit um from cheers right no no no
no he was the other dad in the show CL
uh no uh James Bond George lasenby oh
he's a hard Australian yeah now George
lasenby played me dad but originally we
had Paul Hogan now George L me if you
don't know it was it was James Bond one
movie and got so drunk on set he was the
first one after Sean conry he he bought
a gun he would get drunk and like throw
cans in the air and shoot him and and
then he was signed on to like six James
Bond movies right but he showed up at
the premere of his movie with a big long
beard all drunk in Australian
like this and they're like can you go
home and please cut your hair and look
like James Bond you it's
the 70s peace and love Daddy
don't shave off no beard right and
they he goes do you want out of this
film and he went yeah I'm going to be a
big star and they had the contract
waiting and he signed his way out and
then for the rest of his career he was
like villains on Bruce Lee movies oh wow
like he was one of like Bruce Le's
coffin beares but he was the number one
male model in the world in
1964 and he played my dad and then a
movie a woman called Magnus sansky
played my mother now she's a famous
Australian
pull her up uh played my mother right
now now Magda Magda Magda subky you
thought his mom's name was Magnus no su
su there she is there she is now Magnus
sansky very funny woman been in lots of
movies and stuff you'll know it as the
farmer's wife out of the movie Babe in
the sequel babe pig in the city there
you go she got to wait Rose so she gets
to play she gets to play my mother right
and so my father finds out that he's
being played by James Bond and he's
pretty excited he's walking around the
house all day I'm James Bond James Bond
me my dad's coming around corners yeah
he's pretty good like he's he's a
carpenter from Sydney who all of a
sudden is going to be being played by
James Bond he's over the Moon
and I ring the house up and my mother
goes you hate me
don't
and I'm like what what have I done I get
paid by a big fat woman and your father
gets paid by James Bond I don't know why
you hate
me she was a bigger lady right your mom
she was she was a big lady big lady I I
I uh after we and Sam have a story I
have a couple of Sam Morel stories that
I very much enjoy and he can tell the
second one cuz I was too drunk to
remember this one please don't paint me
too bad this put it put it but I'll tell
the F the first one we'll tell the one
about when my mom came home when I came
home from your mom's funeral dude that
was so J I mean I'll started you came
back from Australia I mean I'll tell the
softer one first cuz this one's for
extreme the softer one is when I first
met you I was down we down you always
open up for me at Carolines and and
you're just the the nicest BL and he was
one of the first people to be real nice
to me when I got to America and uh I was
pumped to do that weekend that was you
know and uh I I I got booked after that
to do cig you Hall and and I contacted
you and I said uh now in uh in uh the
rest of the world to open for me but in
the rest of the world we call it a
support Act Right support me right and
so I I I rang Sam up or text him or
something and I said I said hey I'm
playing Carnegie Hall um could you
please come and support me uh I need
support like this and and you went if
that's what you need
you're like a support animal Sam Sam
thought that I was an emotionally
fragile
individual well the next time you were
and then like you show up and I go how
long are you doing and you like this
what are you talking
about okay you you're the iing a tell me
you went on yeah yeah oh thank God no
that was a big deal cuz my parents came
to that show and they were and that was
like a gig where they're like oh
this guy wants Sam to open so they were
like oh okay that was when you I think
you were doing the gun bit too yeah I
just started I just started doing the
gun bit legendary bit one of my favorite
bits I mean that that was that was
awesome yeah the gun the gun bit
I wrote The Gun bit uh because John
ratsenberg who Cliff claven from cheers
right he really is Cliff claven from
cheers oh really that kind's Cliff when
you meet him he's just like I tell you
what does that all day he's like he's
like a like he uh he liked he's a great
guy we're still friends um he uh he only
likes light bulbs with filaments in it
he go I don't like these LED bulbs made
by the Chinese to fuel the China Army he
goes these he goes these Obama bulbs oh
like he's like that far gone right
but you know G it's his opinion right
but anyway anyway I was I was with him
when s that's this isn't the funny bit
but I was with him when Sandy Hook
happened m and we were doing legit I was
sitting next to him and he turned to me
and the first thing he said to me he
goes none of this would have happened if
those teachers had guns oh damn when
will these liberals learn how many lives
there you know what I mean and I was and
I was like are you kidding and I
argued with him for two or three days
and at the end of the two or three days
every joke of that whole 60-minute
routine was was written just arguing
literally with Cliff claven wow like who
gets the privilege of doing that right
you know like he so that guy he so Cliff
claven that that part in
cheers wasn't written it didn't exist he
went into audition to be norm and then
as he was leaving he went hey you have a
bar no all and they went a bar No all he
goes yeah every Bar Needs a bar no all
it's like a guy that stands and goes oh
actually you know that the knowt all was
invented by the Trojans way back in 1876
when the thing with the is that right
and they they from that moment they
wrote that character wow that's crazy
I've never gotten one audition I've
never had a rooll written for me
on a sitcom that's what every audition
now I leave like this just in case like
works you need a rock like like a bloke
who looks like a
rock then I get into the ground I go
like that I go think about it could be
in any
scene damn that's incredible and they
made him a mailman which was
perfect anyway so my mother had died and
I came back you can tell you the rest of
the yeah Jim you messaged me to to
support you again I knew what it meant
this time and uh and I think we're in
like Huntington or something I forget
where where it was but
uh we were drinking and you had drank I
thought I was keeping up with you but
you had had way more than me you were
like putting them back you I was
skipping hiding drinks going off you did
like two hours on stage it was
hilarious I mean it was a lot about your
mom and stuff it was like emotional but
you had great lines my mother
had literally di I'd come back from the
funeral the the the next the next day
was yesterday it was me mon Jesus so we
go we end up at a bar PJ Carney it's a
solid bar in Midtown I don't remember
any of this yeah I remember this quite
well cuz I wasn't nearly as I was
drinking but I was kind of like this is
one of my seven bottoms y there we go
this is front of him well it's but it's
pretty funny we uh and I've never told
this obviously cuz I don't want I would
never tell without your permission but
uh we're in the
bar they're like we're closing in 20
minutes gym in classic gym fashion
throws a 100 on three Ramen Cokes three
Ramen Cokes you know we get six drinks
immediately we're Downing them
whatever I I was like all right I'm
buzz now whatever some I don't
know what you said to some first there
was a heavier woman next to us
very loud talking like at one point she
says something like uh I don't need a
man to take me around town and Jim just
turns to it goes of course not with your
gravitational
pull I was I was an emotional sh she
laughed my mother just passed away but
she she lost it laugh I mean I
was like that's Jim's it's his charm in
the bar so I'm like Jesus Christ
what the hell is going to I'm like I'm
in my head like maybe he's a little
drunker than I thought I don't know next
moment I know he's drunker because I
don't know what you said to some woman
but her boyfriend just like charges and
like what the is going I I stand in
the middle I'm like hey man like he's
you know he's just drunk it's not a big
deal and he's like I'll kill you
I'll kill you and he's like L
like scary dude and I I have a vision of
that yeah and I think I locked myself in
a bathroom no no no he got he got locked
in the bathroom Jim was just like kind
of Jim he barely even noticed this I'm
like dude come on you got to chill out
I'm like trying to put out the fire some
people from the bar some lady which was
pretty badass got in the middle two
dudes grab him throw him in a
bathroom lock him in there so he can't
get out they put like some board in
there to lock him in there he's just
banging like you and I go
Jesus Christ I sit back down Jim goes
one more
drink I was like we got to get the
out of there so I remember walking Jim
back to his hotel and the next day uh
you picked me up in a car we met
something and I was like that was a
night and you go I don't know
what you're talking about I remember one
you told me that I said that you go you
go uh what did you say to that V and I I
turned you went you know me Sam I
wouldn't have said anything
real that's right that's right you
didn't say that Jesus Christ no we had a
couple we had a couple quite a
destructive mood that there was one
other that that was hilarious in
Milwaukee and I don't know what you said
to this guy but I show up I was playing
a this a that one wasn't my fault that
one I remember that one I remember that
one there was like a guy was that the
one in that Spy Bar it was like a like a
you had to have a password to get in
that yeah it's a spy bar yeah I remember
that so there was this room there was
this room there's this room that uh that
that was like a spy bar had James Bond
stuff you had to have his password to
get in and in the back room was a bit
more quiet like a beard gardeny type
area but like a with a roof more Walky
and um
the the the theater I was playing was
over the road so everyone who
had been in the bar had been to the
show so I'm holding court with
like 15 people gathered around me I'm
feeling the situation out I'm roasting
all the people that want to be
roasted right everyone's laughing I'm
crushing and then this bloke walks up
and I'm roasting this one girl because
she said something to me and back and
for everyone laughing he goes hey you
shouldn't speak to a lady like that
right oh boy and he was he was the one
bloke not at the show right he had no
reference point right so he jumps across
and tries to start beating me up
everyone gets tackled and then I turn
around ah
Sam I walk in as this is happening oh my
God I'm like I was just chatting to
people man I walk in as Jim says to the
guy you can't get to me my fans are too
strong
F what the hell did I just walk into
because I lost because it's so funny cuz
a guy tried to punch me with I
surrounded by people who had just come
to the show so it was like this barrier
he just picked the wrong he thought the
girls would be like ah there's a
gentleman sticking up for us but he was
just he picked the wrong situation was
hilarious no I've had some of
the funniest nightes ever with you you
that was a thing I'm glad you're sober
but you were a funny ass drunk I
still I still get high never I still go
out yeah I guess you're not what I don't
I don't go out into bars as much anymore
you know what I mean it's a lot yeah
yeah I and also now it's sort of like
like I host a game show in
Australia just doesn't feel like a game
show type of guy you never saw Pat s
Jack being thrown out the street calling
everyone a did you you wanted to
but yeah
true like Alex TC there was
there never just him out the front of a
burger bar just spouting off and
rubbing his nose calling a woman
fast Alex dreck at a titty bar well she
was rather
beab at least you said it in a clever
way though you got to laugh out of her
yeah reg just filin at of
brothel well there was that guy Access
Hollywood uh p o Brian Bri he he did get
the boot for that great video well I I
like to think I've set somewhat of a
precedent for the but the game show is
weird cuz it's just it is I I
have a game show where I have to only
read 15 questions and I learn the
because I can learn the questions before
I go out there I learn it like a script
because I'm really bad at reading and so
that me biggest fear is the reading of
the questions I'd be good host of is it
cake right he did that I just cake I
could host that show all day one
question Deal or No Deal yes oh that's
in my will house couldn't do
Jeffy to save me life no no nothing with
a speed round if there's a speed round
it's all over Panic yeah I could do
Family Feud cuz all you got to do is
react you know they're like What's six
inches and L's like my husband's penis
and you're like I I tell you what though
what's who's the guy H Harvey Harvey
good at it he
is the greatest game show host in the
world I've done it and the respect I
have for that man and his game show
hosting ability he is second to none
yeah the way that he keeps it light and
he's still somewhat cheeky with him his
laugh seems genuine and he feeds them
laugh he is a cuz I've done it man
it's hard to make them look funny and
make you look funny I can make me look
funny and I try but he he has this
wonderful very good he's good good he's
and I didn't respect him I didn't think
about him you know I mean but the utmost
respect he's the Elvis pres leag game
show host right well this is his calling
is he nailed this you uh you text me a
peeve before the show people who hate
The Beetles yeah people who hate
The Beetles interesting them
because no one hates the Beatles
everybody likes the Beetles everybody
likes everyone has a song from The
Beetles that they enjoy cuz the Beatles
covered every genre or you don't
mind the Beatles but you don't listen to
Here Comes the Sun and think it's
you don't you just don't it's too good
to be it's just it's the same
who don't have TVs it's the same these
oh The Beetles I don't like the
Beetles oh what's your favorite band and
they're always like my my favorite
band's moth there probably is a band
called moth right but you're like and
you're like give me your top 10
moth songs it turns out moth has three
hits I can't get past then I'm like name
me 20 Beetle songs and everyone on Earth
over the age of 20 can name 20 Beetle
songs you just can cuz we all
know them so it's such a it's such a
wank as oh The Beetles suck they they
don't suck even if they're not your
jam they don't suck yes they're too
proud to tell you they're like excited
like they think it makes them cool or
something exactly I'm different and what
makes him suck I I I Paul McCartney went
to the Improv for like week he
was there every night about four or five
years ago he just done Dodger St him and
he went to the Improv and he was sitting
in the corner the whole time and then
you like like no one knew he was in the
room he just sat in the corner Booth
with his with his guitarist and the
staff told us oh by the way Paul
McCartney's in the room and he's just
sitting over there so you're up there
you're doing anal sex jokes the stuff I
do talking about people in the
ass right every now and again you got to
look over and see if Paul's
laughing good cuz you I you desperately
want po Cy to like you you don't want
him walking out going I hate that guy
that would kill you that would kill you
then You' be the dude who hates the
Beetles so you have to be true to
yourself you have to do your anal sex
bit that's doing at the moment right you
got to do you but and then and then like
I so I remember it was me aiz and Sari
and uh the other one
and and and J appeti and the three of us
aren't mates we've never hang out
together I don't have either of their
phone num just the comics that were on
the Build Together yep and I remember
they went I's in the toilet and we the
three of us went and stood out the front
the security had blocked off the toilet
we stood out the front of the toilet
with our phones in hand like ready to
you know we've just been on stage to
have our bit with Paul yeah and he comes
out and he was jezy was famous
cuz he he he gave us all two seconds of
his time and kept moving enough to make
us happy without stopping it was like
remarkable to watch someone that famous
negotiate through three people totally
he just went like this he goes didn't
know I'd be recognized by you Superstars
hey you were funny oh you're a dirty boy
aren't you hey love your films and then
he was off and we all
went and none and none of us got the
photo wow what a and we were all over
the moon yeah perfect a remember us he
remembered what we just done on stage he
made a little comment about us that
seemed nice yeah fantastic a moment's
better than a photo like one that you
really remember like that I'll tell you
what I don't can understand is why
the is anyone on Earth getting any
autographs anymore oh yeah because if
you meet a person you take a
photo we used to get him as a look this
person touched this thing or this person
so people will come and wait and they'll
they'll get a photo photo with you and
then they'll go and can you autograph
this napkin or something and you're like
what are you doing you've got the photo
I understand if it's a DVD or something
or like a sports Jersey like like a game
that's like the only thing
but but if you or can you put your name
in My Autograph book yes that's a big
one it's a weird one I don't you know
what's the worst one do a shot with me
like I don't want to do a shot with you
I got I get I do meet and greets and
what I do is at the end of me show and I
like talking to people I enjoy talking
to people um I take an edible and some
my meet and greets take about an
hour by Midway through the the hour the
edible kicks in and I'm a bit high for
that last half hour every meeting ch
right you
know that you're talking too much when
someone pays $100 to meet you and they
end the conversation
first yeah you know what I mean that's
when you know You' really blown it
yeah I got to I got to go this person
would do anything to meet you and
they're like yeah all right mate the
meter's running out of you buddy I've
definitely had the moment where someone
recognizes me and then they'll talk to
me for a while and I'm like I think they
want a picture so I'm trying to be
polite so I'm like do you want a picture
and they're like no oh and then you feel
like a real you feel like a real idiot
no I I I I always I got to go you want
did you want a picture like that I try
to make it seem like I'm escaping but I
one I don't like
is
um and every everyone's everyone's dead
nice to you but no one comes up to me
and says they're a fan of me everyone
comes up to me and goes my husband's
your biggest fan my is your biggest fan
I I I got a guy at work who loves you
yes exactly what do you think right you
don't like me I don't mind you Albert
Brooks calls it the comp you suult he's
like if you wait long enough they will
eventually insult you you know like I I
like you but my wife hates youber had
the bit too where Hedberg it was like
someone says they saw me on Letterman
but they didn't say if I was good or not
it just confirmed I was on Letterman I
saw you at the store yeah now he's great
I also have the people who come up to me
and because comedians we talk so much
about our personal life they come they
talk to me with such familiarity they
ask me how my son is they ask me uh
things go good in whatever oh sorry to
hear about after me Mom di sorry to hear
about your mom they'll come up and say
something like that and I think is this
a fan or is it someone I know oh or is
it like a work person like an agent or
something or you know someone I should
be polite to you know right and
so you should be polite to everyone but
but they this might be a big woman
anyway
so so so the woman at the bar run CBS or
something you know you can't be out to
everyone come on now anyway so
gravitational pull was that you so I I I
I I always like sometimes you case it
out and you think oh no this is a work
colleague and you do this one how's your
family going oh yeah just take it just
take a punt you sure how's the kids like
it looks like a dad you check out if
there's how's the wife check if there's
a ring yeah throw it back and it turns
out they don't don't you they're
like w he's a fan and you're getting
creepy right right
kids are you guys working on any bits I
got nothing I got I don't know if
I've run the last one do you have
anything good uh no we meant to try out
a rou might be too dark might be I want
to scare
Jim very sentimental I'm a dad now very
sen we'll try it so I was uh I used to
have a real for black women and I was at
a strip club and used to that's kind of
racist you no long you no longer like
them now they're dead to me can't stand
the entire race no but I'm married now
so you know is so you don't like other
women anymore exactly you just your
dick's dead just only one woman you
attractive in the whole wide world I'm
gay
now I'm with you so uh I was at a strip
club and I was you know this beautiful
black stripper lady was like hey she
could tell I was super into her and
she's like 20 bucks you can touch
anything you want anything you want I
was like hey I'm not falling for that
she's like 20 bucks you can touch
anything it got pretty freaky and I was
like all right and I gave her 20 I
touched her hair and they kicked me
out that be something has that been done
all right all right good that is funny
that that's a bit I think okay great I
haven't I haven't tried it yet yeah yeah
I I didn't think anyone will be upset by
that but no has that been done no okay I
had one I had one that I was working I
don't know if I tried this already but I
got really drunk a couple weeks ago to
steakhous I got up I go home I
get on my phone and like you know I'm
just scrolling Instagram and I'm just
getting Childhood Cancer videos and it
was me up I was like really sad
I was like what the like life is
unfair life is I was up
and I uh I made a huge donation to a
children's cancer hospital and then I I
woke up the next morning I was like that
is a bit more than I would have given uh
sober right which it's like not anything
you can do in that scenario you can't be
like like hello American Express fraud
yeah some stole my card
you know you can't like get it back some
philanthropist took my card I once had
someone steal my credit card I always
thought this would be good in a sitc I
never done it in a bit but someone stole
my S my credit card and the illegal
charges someone R me out there's weird
activity on your card and the illegal
charges were all like Ross buying like
kids shoes and like it was like and
there was like like putting Gasol in a
car and all type of stuff and I thought
to myself I think this person hasn't is
just needs it for a bit so I didn't
report it for 2 weeks oh let them live a
little yeah they weren't doing crazy
purchases it was like they need
yeah right yeah like you put
diers I'm like yeah I just moned it for
a bit I let it keep going you got milk
they not trying to buy Lu and they went
to Whole Foods you're like you you
don't have to yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're allowed to go to refs you're
allowed to get some groceries ra don't
go CRA if I see like like luxury items
yes oh no no no no I had one routine
that I've been I I wrote this week that
I don't know if it'll work as such this
is oh well this is okay so my wife is uh
this might be racist this is how you
find out on a podcast right my wife is
Indian uh visually but she's British so
she sounds she has an English accent
with an Indian face sure it never goes
the other way does
it that's true that's true that's true
has that been done before I'm trying to
picture white British lady have you ever
seen like a British person who's like
who went to like India to go find
themselves and come back I won't do the
voice but uh why like why it I think
they should be part of the bed I won't
do the voice I won't do the voice I'm
not going to do the voice uh but uh
that's true you never see that no you're
right and if you did see it you go I'm
thinking of all the races that I I've
seen white Jamaican voice that's a weird
one what you've seen that yeah yeah
there's like white people in
Jamaica I've never seen the you've never
seen a white person with a Jamaican
voice like that's ay man your man yeah
like how are you what would you like to
I've seen that I've seen that and then
it looks like it feels like I think that
was just the James Franco
movie you know that is that's what they
call like in in London that's like the
British kids all start getting that cuz
they're trying to act all sort of
straight sure sure if you go to Jamaica
you'll meet a white person with a
Jamaican accent you oh that's fun but
accent I love that
guyed Hanks we got to get him on
here like he like how easy did you want
life man how easy did you want it like
like imagine if you came from a tough
life man like it you this dude
right he's like my dad was never around
and even then he's still doing all right
yeah everything's still fun he's great
he still has a probably good life yeah I
got to say I'm concerned about your your
feed though on IG it's like kids doing
Lego bits cancer kids what up oh you got
a point well I left I only put in the
clean
Parts uh why you why are you looking at
kids doing cancer it was one video that
came up it was kids doing cancer kids
kids doing cancer material no uh it was
it was a basketball player with like a
kid who had cancer and he was like so
was it was B it was a basketball clip
but it was a kid with cancer got it I
got a lot of basketball in there I think
it's a funny bit though oh it's a great
bit I'll play with it there's a lot
there too um that's that's the whole
thing like with any like disease or
disability if you make a joke about any
of them I don't give a if there's a
person in my audience with that disease
or that disability because I like to
think people can see that I'm joking
right yeah the J about me though it's
the one one time I have a problem is
when and this happen several times
someone stands up and goes hey my kid's
deaf and you
go but I would I would
let let a de adult read the joke yeah
that could be funny angle they'll never
hear
it where how did you how did you do it
how did you do it you're the one with
the bad hearing you're the one then you
made the joke but when he did it you did
it but you did it so mean spirited when
you did it a f bloody mean person I got
one can I ask you if this is should drop
this and I'm probably going to drop it
anyway cuz it's got a shelf life but cuz
it's about the Dylan moany Bud Light
thing but I think like it's just a
little over I'm probably going to drop
it but I'll tell you anyway well I say I
like that Dylan moan was on the Bud
Light can because I would I would look
at the can and when i' find her
attractive I would know that I can't
drive home oh that's fny you got to keep
though that's a great angle I've heard
that bit you got to keep that yeah okay
I was thinking about dropping it that's
good all right well I'll drop this one
the main shooting at the bowling alley
got did he buy did he get did he rent
the SHO use you know they like what what
size he's like
AR-15 all right I'll drop it I like the
first part okay I think give me the end
of your joke again so you when I find
her attractive I know that I can't drive
home yeah that's great and then case the
tag after this because I have to go to
her place the
her there we go that's funny hold on I
got one of about Chinese Whispers I'm
working out here Jim where are you going
to be on the road coming up man uh when
does this come out I I haven't sold out
the Beacon tonight I need help with
that dude no tomorrow sold out I just
want it to be known that Friday sold
very well thank you you added you added
yeah we added a show that did not sell
out there was an added performance um
I'm going to be in like Tyson's uh Tyson
that's a great room uh it's basic DC I
I'm I'm going to be
Austin uh
Dallas H some place there with in
Oklahoma Oklahoma Tyson's Virginia and
then Los Vegas will tie us out the year
and then you know just go to Jim
jeff.com for all other dates also I have
a podcast Vegas the week after me I'm
Missing You by I don't know about that
podcast you you're you're doing the same
uh you're doing the Hard Rock or the I'm
doing the wi oh you're doing you
get the nice golf course I don't get the
nice golf course do you golf I do I I've
got my brothers coming out to to damn
for the month of December and we're
going to go do Australian we're going to
do like a golf trip I I'll tell you
about when we get up the got a funny
story that I I'm not I don't want to
mention here all right CU after the
things that have been said this one's
too sensitive I hear
you um is that is it March then de Mo's
in March Kansas City and March also Cape
Town is that Cape Town South Africa yeah
we yeah yeah we don't have to go this
far ahead I'll be doing I'll be doing
other podcast before we get to
April of
2024 let's just let's just promote the
next couple of what are you
blind this isn't the last promotion I'll
ever do uh I got uh maybe I'll get the
Jeff mm for Australia so I got Australia
coming up all over I got uh Vegas
Florida yeah Fort Myers Tampa then I'm
doing some clubs before I tape a new
special in in March so all over Buffalo
some and uh I was about to do
this for all my Australian fans got out
and see Sam and then I remember this is
your
podcast we might get a bump from you
though hey you never know I'm watching
steo now because of you
all right I'll be opening for that fat
10-year-old and uh I'll be
in Denver uh the beacon Hartford
conquered mobile New Orleans Santa Rosa
Sacramento you can go Mark noran
comedy.com buy some Bodega cat we got
our own whiskey and uh get on the
patreon or what get some merch we have I
don't even know if we do I assume um you
can hear that oh hold on that's uh time
to take your
medicine birth control alarm thanks for
listening guys see you next
[Music]
week's the roof
cop and naked Samuel is feeling
dangerous I'm out to lunch here in New
New Orleans this woman doesn't look like
I remember her and I get down in the
same
way we
might
be
true